good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will be enjoying presentations
on Fridays from leading thinkers about
the issues the promise the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these include
delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle is now open
and we encourage Junior faculty members
who are working in the areas such as
infectious diseases epidemiology
clinical medicine population Health as
well as data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe that this
will be an exciting and engaging program
we're characterizing the secondary
health effects of covid-19 necessitate
unique quantitative and collaborative
approaches
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
Leverage The presentations such as
you're going to hear today as vital
material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023. so
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Maria sundaram from
Marshfield Clinic Research Institute
Maria is an associate research scientist
at the Marshfield Clinic
and she attended the University of
Minnesota for earning her doctoral
Philosophy degree in environmental
health Johns Hopkins University getting
a Master's in science and public health
specializing Global disease epidemiology
and control and did her Bachelor of
Science work in Neuroscience in German
at the University of Wisconsin-Madison
her current research involves estimating
the burden of respiratory viruses like
influenza covid and RSV and estimating
the effectiveness of vaccines in use for
them and continuing our 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series
theme her lecture is entitled challenges
in estimating vaccine Effectiveness
using big data in her presentation Maria
is going to remind us that estimates of
covid-19 vaccine Effectiveness rely
heavily on large-scale data systems such
as national health insurance plans
however there is a temptation to believe
that since these data sets are so big
and have such high penetrance that
epidemic logical bias does not play a
large role however Maria is going to
Avail us of that assumption and we'll
point out that there are several
important challenges to causal inference
with big covid-19 data and she's going
to walk us through what these challenges
are and discuss possible solutions as
always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you are watching on YouTube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they might have via the chat feature in
their Zoom sessions I will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome
Maria we are so excited to have you and
we're really looking forward to your
lecture
thank you so much for having me um I'm
I'm really looking forward to talking
about this and all of the ways that
vaccine Effectiveness research has
gotten like messed up because of
covid-19 and I hope that it'll be useful
and interesting to folks listening uh
and I'm looking forward to your
questions so I just first wanted to talk
a little bit about why I care about
vaccines why why vaccines in particular
for me
um there's all sorts of reasons there's
probably a lot of obvious reasons um but
for me there's a there's a couple big
ones vaccines are the only Public Health
intervention to have ever eradicated a
disease this is a photo of rahima Banu
the last person to get wild uh smallpox
um it's also the only Public Health
intervention that we know of that's
capable of eliminating diseases from
from uh regions in fact we can see here
um our efforts to contain polio have
been incredibly strengthened by the fact
that we have a great vaccine a great set
of vaccines and the who estimates this
is actually pre-covered
um estimated that
that's between 2010 2015. which is a
crazy amount when you think of the the
number of possible things
um that could be happening to cause
those deaths
so this is why I think vaccines are so
wonderful and important and I'm sure you
don't need to hear more from me on why
vaccines are great we've all kind of
lived through an example of why vaccines
work uh over the last couple of years uh
but uh there is of course like you know
a little bit of a gap there um and so I
want to tell you why not only vaccine so
there's a couple of problems that
vaccines can't solve uh for example you
know from the time that you develop this
little vaccine in a vial and you've got
your syringe to the time that it gets to
the person's arm and protects them
there's a lot of intervening factors um
there can be waning immunity from the
vaccine there could be a safety signal
as well for example we saw this for
covid-19 and the J J vaccine
um
with immune thrombocytopenia
um we could see lags or problems in
vaccine production we saw that several
times in several different ways
throughout the covid-19 pandemic and
they may actually be in environments
where you maybe wouldn't expect
um for example Canada is a great example
um that at the time did not have
in-country vaccine manufacturing
capability
um because why would they do that they
can get it from the United States and
then during a global pandemic a
respiratory virus it actually suddenly
becomes really important that we have
that capability and because Canada
didn't have that capability not only
were vaccine uh vaccines delayed for the
rollout in Canada but also they wound up
taking vaccines out of Kovacs earlier
than they were supposed to and so this
kind of had Global rapper competitions
just because of the fact that they had
sold their in-country vaccine
manufacturing capability
and we've seen also kind of on that same
line vaccine nationalism and how
vaccines get distributed it's not always
directly related to the amount of meat
or burden that is caused by the
infectious disease that it prevents and
along those same lines vaccine Equity
even more uh in in small smaller areas
in a country
we can see that vaccine Equity is really
important for a lot of different reasons
as well as vaccine hesitancy let's say
we solve all those problems that we get
the person in the room and we've got the
the vaccine in the syringe and the
person is like you know what I'm just
not really into it I don't really like
vaccines it's not really my thing so
that's that's also a problem we have to
get that person on board and get them
excited about getting vaccinated because
it's a really great Public Health
intervention and if they're not on board
with that then all of the work we did
um doesn't doesn't really help us there
um so we have plenty of of research and
work that um kind of tries to address
those particular uh different red X's
but luckily for us like once we get the
vaccine in the person we get some nice
data out and then we publish the paper
and we have done it we've like reported
the the uh how That vaccine works and
it's done right like that's the we don't
need to do anymore
work okay well obviously that's not true
right so we have challenging challenges
of testing we have challenges with
vaccine Equity as well as ascertainment
of whether you got vaccinated and also
whether you have covid-19 for example
um not limited to cover 19. and we also
have a lot of different violations of
model assumptions and study design
requirements that are not being followed
because we really don't have control
over what's happening kind of in this
like nitty-gritty real world
scenario where everything is changing
from day to day week to week and so my
goal in talking to you today is not
really to solve these problems these X's
these are way above my pay grade I just
want to give you an idea of like where
there might be dragons
um and the reason I have a dragon up
here is that some of you may know this
is probably like an apocryphal story but
um there is this idea that when people
were making Maps way way before now when
they didn't know what was out there
um one of the practices of map making
was to draw a dragon in an area that
hadn't been explored and that was kind
of like a note to just be like well we
don't know what's out here but it could
be dangerous it could be really bad it
could be a Dragon for example
um this might not actually be what that
makers really did but I like the story
and I like this illustration so my job
my like goal here today is just to tell
you kind of like where are some of the
Dragons
um and hopefully that will um kind of
spark some ideas about like what to do
with with the data you might already
have or how to interpret data that
you're seeing reported on
so
with that said vaccine effectiveness
um vaccine Effectiveness a lot of you
may know is calculated by uh taking a
risk ratio or like a relative risk of
some kind uh and you know we take it
we've got like one minus that and that's
our vaccine Effectiveness estimate so
um we can evaluate this relative risk
almost any way we choose which is kind
of incredible and so this kind of starts
to ask you know beg the question vaccine
Effectiveness against what
um we can look at a lot of different
outcomes here we can look at individual
risk against infection or transmission
symptomatic illness severe illness
um illness progression rate how fast you
get really sick versus you know
hopefully not really thick
um and we can also estimate indirect
effects of vaccine Effectiveness so VE
for unvaccinated individuals in a highly
vaccinated population
um otherwise maybe referred to as heart
immunity or Community immunity or
vaccine Effectiveness or vaccinated
individuals that is beyond what the
protection that they would have gotten
just from their own vaccine alone thanks
to the fact that everyone around them is
vaccinated and I just want to kind of
like quote from this paper this is the
best talent paper from 1999. she really
was ahead of the curve on so many of
these things
um to just you know she kind of really
makes this really great point that in a
lot of vaccine studies the distinction
between infectious infection and disease
as an outcome is not actually made and
so when we don't differentiate these
protective effects it's between
infection and against disease we
introduce these non-linear causal
Pathways and that could mean that the
efficacy that we're measuring
um is quite different than what we meant
to measure so I'm going to go into that
a little bit more in the next couple of
slides but again this is from this is
actually from a different that's how
we're in paper in 1997. so hopefully
this is a kind of an illustration of all
of the different possible ways you could
use models to investigate vaccine
Effectiveness
um
we have a couple of different ways that
we seem to go back to over and over
again because they seem to work for the
the different environments that we
usually see but um in a pandemic a lot
of things kind of fall apart and so we
have to kind of investigate them a
little more carefully so one of the core
assumptions of observational vaccine
effectiveness of nation is that people
are exchangeable people who do get
vaccinated and who don't get vaccinated
are exchangeable except for their
vaccination status so other another way
to say this is they're flip-floppable
they live similar ideally identical
lives except for the fact that the
theater didn't get vaccinated but people
in vaccine Effectiveness studies can be
different in really important ways so
I'm going to go now into a bunch of
stuff about covid-19 and I just want you
to try to keep in mind it's not
necessarily just restricted to covid-19
the kind of things that I'm talking
about it's just that we have the best
data and illustrations for coping 19.
this is a good example of where people
who might be taking part in a vaccine
Effectiveness
um data set who might be a member of a
vaccine Effectiveness data set
um are not necessarily exchangeable so
this is in New York City we can see that
there is differences
um by area in the amount of tests that
are available we can also see that
there's almost like a reverse difference
in the proportion of positive tests
available
we can see that that kind of maps onto
socioeconomic status we can see that it
maps onto ethnicity and race
and so now we're kind of seeing like
okay actually the structure of something
that we thought was exchangeable
everyone can get a test is actually not
really the case and there are some there
are some really important structural
factors including socioeconomic factors
uh that are coming into play here
um and that's that's not just um we're
not just
um you know talking about testing
um in a community level we're talking
about testing that's we're attempting to
deliver the test directly to people's
homes uh but for tests goes a long way
uh in some homes and doesn't go a long
way in some other homes and that is also
sort of differential by these
socioeconomic and racial ethnic
variables
um this is a picture of uh my home state
of Wisconsin's health impact of Cova 19
by race and ethnicity
um you will not be surprised that um
although Wisconsin is a majority white
State
um the number of hospitalizations per
100 000 people fell uh most heavily on
black wisconsinites unfortunately it's
it's sad that this happened it's also
sad that it's not surprising
um but but it's an important component
um of our covid
um a pandemic shape and then finally I
want to talk a little bit about vaccine
access so this is actually a map of
Toronto
um where like the the underneath part
that's all white is um Lake Ontario
so
um so you can see here that again these
kind of two different heat maps are
almost flip floppable they're almost
like reverse images of each other
um on the left you see covid-19
hospitalizations on the right you see uh
the population that's vaccinated with at
least one dose and this was in April of
2021.
um and just to kind of like Hammer that
point home a little bit more
um in the upper left you can see this is
a neighborhood of uh Toronto that's uh
maybe a little bit rougher around the
edges this is like the part of Toronto
that Drake raps a lot uh about
um it's the intersection of Jane and
Finch and you can see here um this is a
community that could really use a lot
more help and money and structure than
they currently have and you can see in
particular they don't have a lot of
pharmacies and there's also challenges
in getting people to those pharmacies
and then in the bottom right in this
pink area is Mount Pleasant which is one
of the nicer neighborhoods in Toronto
and I'll I'll cop to it and tell you
that I also lived in Mount Pleasant when
I was a postdoc somehow on my postdoc
salary so you can see the little blue
dot right next to this uh Pink um Square
here is pretty close to where I lived
you can see uh there's 29 pharmacies in
this area as opposed to six pharmacies
that Jaden Finch and this is it's pretty
clear that like Mount Pleasant is the
sort of folks who are able to work from
home who have a lot of social capital
and economic capital who are able to
access care very easily and this is
maybe not the the specific neighborhood
that needs the vaccines the most uh like
you know and and the most urgently but
um because of the underlying structures
of Toronto uh that's the that's the
neighborhood that got the most vaccines
up front
um and this is mirrored again uh in
Wisconsin uh vaccination rollout um we
see that there is substantial vaccine
inequity within our communities
so vaccination
um not only is there kind of this like
social like underpinning of
um of vaccine inequity and testing and
Equity
um there's also kind of like biological
reasons why the vaccine might do
different things for different people so
vaccination can induce heterogeneous
responses and the protection might win
or be boosted
um you know based on your underlying uh
immunological condition
um you might be protected or unprotected
you might have weighty immunity over
time or you might have natural immune
boosting after exposure to a wild type
virus a virus that's circulating kind of
in your community
um depending on who you are you might be
susceptible to vaccine-mediated
protection
um or the sorry the virus might be
susceptible to vaccine mediated
protection that's why it's sad
um or depending on the virus that you
get infected with it might be a very end
of concern and it might Escape immune
detection or protection based on who you
are and what your risk factors are where
work on the time of the pandemic where
you are you know needing to be outside
or interacting with people
and um
there are also of course differences in
Behavior conditional on vaccination
status on the left here I have people
who maybe they've been vaccinated so now
they're like they are feeling great and
they want to go out to a race
um you know on the other hand there's
maybe someone who um either is high risk
and has been vaccinated or hasn't gotten
vaccinated yet and now they're they're
alone and both of these people are in
orange just to indicate that like
neither of these scenarios is great I
don't want people sitting alone by
themselves on a bench so this is this is
not great so when um so I'm really like
kind of dig into some of these things
and you might be thinking well okay yeah
like all of these things are true and
that's fine but this is why we put these
covariates in regression models so we
put the covaries on the regression
models and then we're done and like that
solves the problem and um I mean of
course that's not entirely true but that
is why we put these things in our
question models
um I want to kind of dig into where that
Paradigm falls apart a little bit so
there are some times when controlling
for things in regards models simply
won't work and a great example of this
is when other things are happening at
the same time so when this happens the
functional result is we don't have
anyone in our comparison groups so in a
scenario where circulation of pathogens
and the vaccination of specific risk
groups are consistent over time we can
just measure vaccine effectiveness at
different times after vaccination so we
can measure it at 14 days after
vaccination or 140 days and that's
that's fine but if the circulation of
the pathogen is not consistent over time
which is something that we saw for
coca-19 then different measurements of
ve at different time points could
accidentally coincide with the
vaccination of a new risk group so maybe
you know we we've moved on past older
adults and Care Homes and healthcare
workers now we're starting to vaccinate
middle-aged adults
um so this is like a completely new you
know different group with different
underlying immunological uh experiences
repertoires and uh functions
um and that's the vaccine might work
differently for them
um it could also accidentally coincide
with a sudden increased transmissibility
of a new pathogen or a subtype
um the changing of other pathogen
prevention measures like for example
maybe uh throughout the course of this
we now have a directive from the local
public health department that we're
supposed to cough directly out of the
eyeballs of the person sitting next to
us on the bus
so anyway
um you get the idea um
we as a result of these kind of
structural confounding factors ve can be
biased in either direction towards an
hour away from it all and this actually
is um very very challenging
um because we don't really have a way to
change the fact that these things have
already happened policy has been enacted
we can't turn back time we can't we
don't have a time machine
um but wait there's more
so sometimes controlling for these
things we know our confounders uh maybe
we do have the opportunity to control
for them and uh there is no kind of
structural confounding we we feel like
from a Time standpoint
um things are okay but when we put that
covariate into our regression model or
when we condition on it it makes
everything worse and I'm going to try to
explain a little bit about how this
works it's called collider bias and I
will say collider bias is something that
does not come intuitively to me it
probably does come intuitively to some
people but I'm not one of those people
so okay let's go through this example
um oh sorry in causal models the
collider is an entity that's caused by
more than one factor in the graph I'm
about to illustrate this for you but if
you are a dag person just know that a
collider is a node that like two edges
are going into so we'll go for through
this example imagine a world where
asthma has no relationship to the risk
of covid-19 infections so we like
underlying truth is asthma is not
related to cover 19. but we don't know
that yet and we want to investigate
whether asthma and covet are related
we're interested in this relationship we
dutifully set up our causal model here's
our dag having asthma and then we have
an arrow and then identified as a
covenant case
and we want to identify this Arrow here
we want to quantify that
so in order to measure this Arrow let's
say we have a pool of 100 people and 10
of whom unbeknownst to us yet have kova
19. and of these 100 people 50 of them
have asthma
okay so now we know like you know under
underlying like this is again the
underlying truth we just unbeknownst to
us yet because asthma is not related to
covid although we don't know it yet
asthma is randomly distributed
throughout the group and
um I hope without any further
information from me you'll be able to
calculate the expected number of covik
cases in the 50 of people with asthma
I'll give you just a second to think
about that
it's five so we we know that there's ten
percent of people uh in this group that
have covid and we know that asthma covet
are not related so the number of people
that have asthma covet is the same
number as the number of people without
asthma who have coping it's five
so this is this is the equation here in
case you would like the equation there
it is okay so that's how it could have
happened if we did actually sample
everyone we meant to and we specified
our model correctly we would get the
correct answer
but that's not really how it sometimes
does happen so in reality the character
answer is a lot harder to get to because
we don't know we don't get to know about
Cova cases that aren't identified
through testing
so although this wasn't explicit in our
question because of the way we're
conducting our research we're actually
conditioning on getting tested for covid
and let's just say let's just make this
one step worse let's say if you can only
get a test if you have relevant symptoms
like shortness of breath
um this is hopefully not too far outside
the realm of possibility from your
personal experience especially at
certain points in the pandemic where
tests are not widely available or a
certain type of test is not widely
available like a PCR
and so this is the real causal model
here we've conditioned on getting tested
for covid and now we've conditioned on
this collider and that introduces this
relationship between asthma and covid
where there isn't one in real life
so I'll try to prove this to you now
um in our observational study structure
we have these hundred people we have 55
people who got a Kobe test because they
had coveted symptoms
we know among these 55 people whoever
doesn't have covid must have asthma this
is a this is a fake world where anyone
with coveted symptoms can only have
these two causes so the risk of covid
among non-asthmatics is now one
because all of the people who had
coveted asthma got tested but the risk
of covet among asthmatics is still 5 out
of 50.
and because we've subset our data just
to these individuals we're able to get a
covet test we've now got a risk
difference that is actually very
different than zero
but this is going to make it seem like
covet is more common in people without
asthma and an alternative explanation if
you look at the data if you just look at
the data an alternative explanation is
asthma protects you against covid
and I just want to underline here
this is the risk difference not the risk
ratio so we're comparing 0.9 to a null
value of 0.
okay
so we have the opportunity to
investigate the actual magnitude of this
potential collider bias using
um individuals in Ontario Canada so I I
didn't mention this in the beginning but
I did a postdoc in Toronto
um and we took while I was living there
um health information from everyone
who's enrolled in the Ontario health
insurance plan
Ontario has a single-payer healthcare
system so this is 14.7 million
individuals almost every single person
who lives in Ontario
and we had information about their
Covenant status we had information about
a lot of underlying health conditions
like asthma COPD we had information
about their hospital visits we had
information about their age in their
neighborhood so we took a look we were
like okay like what is
a determinant for getting covid-19 in
Ontario but then we started to realize
we actually didn't have an idea of like
what the correct reference group would
be so I'm going to illustrate this to
you now in the First Column here we have
tested versus not tested so we're
comparing people who were tested for
covid-19 versus people who are not
tested and in the second column we've
got people who tested positive versus
tested negative among all of the tested
individuals and in the last column we
had testing positive versus not testing
positive so that that comparison
category now is not just testing
negative it's people who tested
negatives plus people who were not
tested
and as you can see here
let's just go with asthma we see that
you were slightly more likely to be
tested for covid-19 if you had asthma
but you were less likely to test
positive if you had asthma
and if we go down to COPD it's actually
a little bit more of a magnitude you
were really like definitely more likely
to be tested for covid-19 if you had
COPD less likely to test positive but
then we saw you were more likely to test
positive if the comparison group was
people who tested negative plus people
who didn't get tested
okay so the 95 count of Fitness interval
includes one so maybe maybe we wouldn't
like interpret that as a big deal
um but then when we look at Hospital
admissions so these are these are high
risk people people who've been admitted
to the hospital three or more times in
the last three years these are people
who have some kind of like serious
underlying condition for some reason
they're definitely more likely to get
tested for cover 19. this is maybe not
surprising we're worried about them we
want to make sure that they don't have
cover 19. they're less likely to test
positive if we compare them to people
who test negatives but they're more
likely to test positive if we compare
them to people who test negative plus
people who are in tested because they're
tested so often and this is a
statistically significant result and not
only that in in the epidemiology world
1.38 with this like tight of a
confidence interval that's a pretty
convincing finding that's like something
that you normally wouldn't necessarily
attribute to just bias Alone
um and it also kind of makes sense with
our mental model that if you are a
high-risk person you're more likely to
test positive for cover 19.
and I'll kind of like again illustrate
this by age group so Inland tested
versus non-cat uh not tested category
you're less likely to be tested if
you're younger
in general the older you get the more
likely you are to be tested although
it's not necessarily A strictly linear
relationship
and let's look at these 85 and up year
olds you are incredibly more likely to
be tested uh for kova 19 and then you're
more likely to test positive in either
scenario depending on
um you know which comparison group you
you have but
um the values for these differ by an
incredible amount just a huge magnitude
of difference depending on your
comparison group and so this leads to
challenges interpretation the
extraordinarily challenging thing here
is that there's also biological reasons
why for example asthma might protect
against covid-19 and of course
conversely there's also biological
reasons why people with asthma would
conceivably have a worse time with kova
19 and I can tell you from experience
that was uh what happened with me and so
this really serves to completely muddy
the Waters of causal inference and we
have papers that are like well you know
maybe it's better if you have asthma
maybe it is protective
so this is extraordinarily challenging
right because this could be due to
collider bias but it could also be a
real biological finding
and Beyond the challenges of controlling
for confounders and regression models I
hope this illustrates that this there's
some pitfalls in not really knowing
who's in your study population because
this is kind of what it comes back to
right like who are these people who have
asthma are they like a 36 year old who
has exercise abuse asthma because she's
living a very sedentary lifestyle after
covet or is this like a 75 year old
person who's had lifelong severe asthma
there's like there's differences here
right
um not knowing who is in our population
can happen really easily in scenarios
when we want an answer quickly we want
the answer to be based on a large number
of people who are just living their
lives they're not in a clinical trial
it's challenging when our academic
structures don't reward community-based
participatory research or long-term
engagement with the communities that we
study although that's a whole other
presentation for a different day
and it's relatively easy and fast to use
administrative data I'm not saying it's
easy and fast I'm saying it's relatively
easy and fast comparing you know
compared to a prospective cohort study
or a clinical trial
we've got the data already let's just
use it
so one of these pitfalls of not knowing
your population is something called the
healthy vaccinate effect
so in this particular scenario
individuals who get vaccinated are more
able they're more mobile they're more
likely to access care and you can kind
of think back to the picture I showed
you of the different Toronto
neighborhoods Jane and Finch versus
Mount Pleasant these people who do get
access to the vaccine may be healthier
at Baseline and they therefore might be
less likely to get the disease in
question separately from their
vaccination status so being healthy
before vaccination is kind of
confounding the relationship between
receiving a vaccine and getting infected
and this actually biases the ve away
from the null and it makes it look like
the vaccine works better than it does
um however in a different scenario would
also might be happening simultaneously
uh we might prioritize the vaccine first
to older adults and other individuals at
high risk of the disease in questions
and in this case being unhealthy before
vaccination affects both your likelihood
to receive a vaccine and your likelihood
of getting infected
so you can see how this would also bias
ve and then we have an additional sort
of like potential unhealthy vaccine
effect what is the vaccine series is
more than one dose
so those who make it to two doses might
actually be healthier than those who get
infected before the second dose or
unfortunately die before the second dose
um so does this mean that dose 1
presents a higher infection risk
compared to dose two
pretty clearly not but that's kind of
what it looks like when you look at the
data and so both of these are going to
buy a CE towards the null make it look
like the vaccine doesn't work as well as
it actually does
so it's becoming more obvious that in
addition to age high-risk health status
calendar time and sex these are kind of
The Usual Suspects confounders of
respiratory virus transmission studies
we should probably also add Healthcare
seeking Behavior to the list because we
want to know like who are these
high-risk people that are always kind of
coming in and needing care
and I'll also just take a moment to
acknowledge that I'm using the word
Behavior but there's all sorts of
structural factors that go into whether
someone is able whether it's feasible to
seek Care at a particular time in a
particular space
um so using a specific study design
which is called the test negative design
we can try to account for some of the
differential Healthcare seeking between
cases and non-cases and that's actually
what this the main benefit of the test
negative design is to try to account for
this Healthcare seeking behavior I'm
just going to explain a little bit how
the test negative design Works you've
got a cohort of people these people are
living in your community throughout the
course of a winter respiratory virus
season or some other kind of like you
know season of and of an illness that is
preventable by a vaccine so these people
are vaccinated and some of them are not
vaccinated
and a subset will come in to your clinic
your study clinic or just maybe your
hospital clinic and they'll say you know
what I have a respiratory virus I have a
I have a respiratory infection uh let's
say and they'll have all of the symptoms
that um maybe make you think that they
could have the disease that you're
interested in in questions
so
they get pathogen tested by PCR we find
out their vaccination history through
their medical record and then we get
some other demographic information from
them either from the medical record or
we we ask them directly
some of these people will turn out to be
pathogen negative and those people are
test negative people
and the other group of people will turn
out to be pathogen positive
um and those are test positive people
and now we have
uh now we just have to compare those
people using an odds ratio and we
calculate the veas in that odds ratio
I just want to actually note here for
terminology in case anyone has heard
these terms before sometimes this is
referred to as a case control test
negative design study and in fact this
design actually doesn't have much in
common with the typical case control
study another way to think about this
might be a cohort study where everyone
who doesn't have the clinical case
definition
gets ignored
um so I'm gonna blow my nose real quick
okay
there is an important similarity however
for the test negative design to case
control studies and that's the selection
in a test negative study is based on the
outcome
just like in a regular case control
study this is because only people with
symptoms are seeking care
okay
test negative design we use it all the
time for influenza vaccine effectiveness
um and it's kind of a logical choice for
covid-19
um vaccine Effectiveness and I'm sure if
you go on PubMed right now and you type
in sarsko V2 test negative design you're
going to find at least a thousand papers
compared to co-work studies the test
negative design is less susceptible to
misclassification of the outcome
um
and it's less susceptible to confounding
by Healthcare seeking Behavior but it
also carries with a few assumptions and
one of those is that vaccinated and
unvaccinated people come into contact
with infectious people at the same rate
the
two distance for influenza we know that
influenza circulating of the community
it's kind of hard to tell apart from
other respiratory viruses that maybe
don't cause as much severe disease like
adenovirus or rhinovirus
for covid-19 It's actually kind of a
challenging assumption to make we we do
know a little bit more uh about people's
infectious status with covid-19 than we
generally do during a regular winter flu
season we assume that diagnostic tests
has high sensitivity and specificity
this is actually a pretty good
assumption both for flu and for covid-19
although the strength of that assumption
was different throughout the course of
the pandemic and it's also changing a
little bit with our you know kind of
main Reliance now on rapid tests versus
PCR tests
um we also have a requirement in the
test negative design that we only
include individuals who seek care for
acute respiratory illness
during a time when the pathogen of
interest is actively circulating
for for covid-19 this is a pretty decent
assumption
excuse me
that um that it's been circulating more
or less this whole time but you can kind
of see that like we might be more likely
or less likely to find someone who's
positive based on what's happening in
the community if there's a lot of
vaccine or if there's a lot of
transmission events happening in the
community versus not
finally we have this core Assumption of
the test negative design that
vaccination does not affect your risk of
respiratory illness caused by a pathogen
other than the one that the vaccine is
preventing so I'll kind of translate
this a couple of different ways for
example flu vaccine doesn't affect your
risk of cover 19. or your risk of
respiratory synthetial virus infections
so this is a core assumption about the
test negative design because
um if if it didn't affect your risk of
respiratory illness for other pathogens
then that would kind of bias our test
negative group
and that's a little bit of a challenge
for food this is still it's still a
pretty decent assumption for Copa 19 it
becomes a little more challenging now
because we have this group of people
let's say like a group of people who get
flu vaccine every year
those people are also the people who are
going to be really enthusiastic about
getting covid-19 vaccines so now we have
like a very highly vaccinated population
against two different pathogens and then
we have like the comparison group is
people who are not vaccinated against
either pathogen and in this scenario
hopefully you can kind of see that there
are some connections between
um your your covid-19 vaccination status
and then your risk of influenza or vice
versa
um not intentionally and not even
biologically but just through sheer
force of confounding
um and I just want to kind of add here
to
the test negative design measures
vaccine Effectiveness against a
medically attended acute respiratory
illness so this is functionally a
component of uh infection and severe
illness right so some people will
they'll be vaccinated and they'll get
some kind of mild infection and they
will never seek care in a medical
setting they won't go in to get a PCR
test they won't report this illness and
we won't know about them so your disease
also does have to be severe enough that
you do seek care
um in this you know kind of particular
study design
okay
we haven't touched uh talked much about
this
um I'm just going to talk a little bit
about it
um because it's a little bit of a bonus
problem in the test negative design
um there is an entirely new layer of
complexity to these inference challenges
and we can add another season to the mix
this is relevant to influenza um we have
influenza Seasons that up until recently
were
pretty pretty consistently happening
over the the winter period
um but we also will very likely have
this kind of very similar almost
seasonal thing happening with covid-19
in the future maybe it won't be exactly
the same shape as influenza maybe it
won't be the same periodicity as
influenza but we can already see that
there are waves happening
um and so there's going to be different
times of like Peak covid-19 transmission
and infection
so you can kind of Imagine like in one
season season one on the left here we've
got confounders uh you've got a
vaccination status in season one and
you've got an infection status in season
two and then like fast forward a year
you have like a you know probably like a
pretty consistent set of confounders
maybe you know like your age is a little
bit different maybe your socks is the
same
um you have a vaccination status in
season two and you have an infection
status in season two but you know
usually kind of the way it functionally
works is that you're a person who either
does get vaccinated or doesn't get
vaccinated especially with regard to flu
vaccine
people who get vaccinated usually get
vaccinated every year
um and people who don't get vaccinated
don't really care about it and don't
usually get vaccinated and so these kind
of like statuses are linked uh just by
sheer force of human behavior
um and that kind of means that your
vaccination status last season could
protect against your infection status in
the next season it could protect you
that long
um so that's a little bit of a challenge
because now we have like this kind of
direct causal linkage between your
previous season status and your current
season status of course if you were
infected last year you might also have a
reduced risk of infection this year or
maybe you're a high-risk person and you
get infected every year which really
sucks but that also um kind of like
serves as this causal linkage between
your infection status and your previous
year in the current year
and this kind of serves to artificially
link the confounders in season one and
the confounders in season two
and so we've looped these Seasons
together to an extent where these
confounders are now related and so if we
want to assess vaccine Effectiveness in
season two we're now at the point where
we need to start going back to season
one and maybe season zero and season
minus one to find out like what were the
confounders at that time because now
we've made our model
sufficiently linked together that these
confounders are informative
okay so that was a lot of talking I'm
just going to recap now
testing inequity coveted inequity and
vaccine inequity are not just bad for
public health they're also bad for
causal immigrants so if we really care
about these as scientists we actually
really have to fight for Equity if only
for the purpose of having better data
quality
knowing your population can have a
really important impact on causal
inference mechanisms by understanding
the potential impact of healthy that can
be bias the potential impact of
unhealthy Saxony bias what else has
happened since you started measuring
waning be for example
whether you might have collider bias
and covid-19 breaks many of the rules
very inconveniently with regard to
exchangeability between the tested and
untested people and the vaccinated and
unvaccinated people Healthcare seeking
behavior in general and your risk of
exposure over time
so
this is uh if I were John Oliver is
where I give you like a very nice neat
solution to these causal inference
problems that I'd encourage you to
strongly to like always do this thing or
I'd give you like a cool hashtag tweet
and I don't have that because much to
everyone's disappointment including my
own I'm not John Oliver so the magical
answer to solving these problems for
those of us who are currently trying to
estimate covid-19 ve is to spend a lot
of time thinking carefully about the
models we've specified but how they may
accurately or inaccurately describe both
our population and the questions we
would like to answer and for those of us
who are attempting to interpret Cova 19
be estimates I hope this presentation is
kind of Illustrated the importance of
carefully reading the methods and the
discussion sections of papers and maybe
it even helps to explain why there is
variability in ve estimates for the same
vaccine in different places or at
different times or in different groups
so with that I just want to send a thank
you out to many of the wonderful people
that have done the science that's kind
of contained within this presentation
um including edlanja my boss at Marshall
Clinic as well as many wonderful
colleagues uh and mentors so I'll stop
talking and I think hopefully now it'll
be time for questions hopefully you guys
have some some questions that you can
challenge me with and we can we can talk
about test negative design and covid-19
and Big Data
Maria I think you're giving John Oliver
a run for his money here you should look
out for his job uh thank you so much for
what a fantastic presentation uh I've
got so many questions
um you know you talked about vaccine
nationalism and equity and and uh you
know a number of different factors which
influence some of this uh kind of work I
also you know couldn't help but notice
back in the when we the vaccines were
coming out that you had the moderna
virus she had the Pfizer uh the fire the
Pfizer vaccine you had you know several
other contenders and those were just
within the U.S and then at other places
around the world and I'm curious that
you know we talk about the vaccine as if
it's like with a capital V but there was
vaccines and I'm curious like how some
of these this modeling has to take into
account not that you just got vaccinated
but by what vaccine you were inoculated
with
yeah you bring up a really excellent
point that I didn't touch on at all
um and there's there's actually a couple
of different reasons why that's super
complex one of them is
um age specific or kind of high risk
specific recommendations for different
vaccines
um for for example in the US now uh you
can't get the jaj unless they're 18 or
over and you kind of would not otherwise
receive a vaccine
um because the US is kind of trying to
prefer mRNA vaccines
um conversely in Canada
um the other adenovirus Vector vaccine
the AstraZeneca vaccine was
um more easily accessible than a lot of
other vaccines and so that was rolled
out first into older adults and then as
we ramped down the the age eligibility
it sort of become clear that maybe it
wasn't as safe for uh for example women
in their 30s and so then we had to like
kind of roll that back a little bit and
say okay actually
um you know now now that we have a
little bit more mRNA vaccine on the
market we're going to make this
recommendation that if you're in your
mid 30s and you're a woman we would
prefer that you get moderna or Pfizer
um but if that's not available and
you're a high-risk person then we want
you to get the vaccine that is available
to you
um and so that like all of these kind of
pieces are changing like in real time
another really good example of that is
again in Canada
um there was a longer delay between the
first and the second primary series
doses
um and I'm a vaccine epidemiologist so I
I'll just kind of like this is like a
very familiar phrase to me
um just to like give you an idea of what
I mean by primary doses like
the first time you got vaccinated
against government 19 is usually it's
probably two doses right so you had you
had to get a shot and then you had to
come back three or four weeks later for
the second shot and that was the end of
your primary series
in Canada we didn't have enough vaccines
to give everyone the primary series on
the schedule that was recommended by the
manufacturer and so my primary series I
received the first dose uh in May and
the second dose in late June um six
weeks later
so that's a fairly normal kind of like
uh way that a lot of Canadians my age
received mRNA vaccines but also due to
uh
you know lack of vaccine I had
heterologist dosing so I received a
Pfizer vaccine for my first primary
series dose and then I received a
moderna for my second primary series
dose because that was just what was
available
um so like all of these there's
challenges in like identifying
biomedically whether heterologous dosing
might have vaccine safety challenges for
different age groups versus maybe it has
increased immunity potential maybe the
extended interval between primary
theories
doses is better long-term for your
immunity but it also increases your risk
short term of getting cover 19. and so
like all of these I I think again I'm
probably not being very satisfying in
like telling you like you should do
always do this always do that when you
see these things in your model but it is
extraordinarily complex and I think
that's your your point is really helpful
to illustrate like the importance of
really understanding what's going on in
the community uh before you dig into the
data
you know I hadn't uh heard about
collider bias before and
um I imagine that it's still an
unfamiliar term to some people
um how did you first kind of encounter
instances where this is going on and uh
is this something that is well
recognized within the epidemiological
community
um because I'm not really sure that data
scientists you know as a species
necessarily attend to things like
collider bias
yeah collider bias is one of those
really odd bugaboos in like
epidemiological epidemiology methods so
there's there's like a whole like
species of epidemiologists that just
focus on causal inference methods and to
then I think collider bias is like
really familiar and very understandable
as you can see it can be hard to wrap
your brain around
um because it's it's this weird like
accident of mathematics that kind of
winds up with like the totally wrong
answer
um it's something that maybe is like on
the same you know in the same category
as something called non-collapsibility
of the odds ratio which is another
problem that the methodologists worry
about a lot and then people who are kind
of like on the ground like trying to
figure out if vaccine works it's not at
the top of our mind
um and so I learned about it in my PhD
program but I really didn't at the time
imagine that it would ever have any kind
of like relevance to me personally and
then when we were doing this analysis in
Ontario we were saying well okay like
what's the correct comparison group for
these people who are testing positive
should we include people who tested
negative
so we include people who tested negative
and were symptomatic should we include
people who test them that have been
we're asymptomatic those people are
probably healthcare workers and they're
probably getting like tested a lot so
maybe they're special
excuse me or weird in some way
and um we wound up doing it all of the
different ways and we were really hoping
that it would be the same uh for every
different comparison group and then it
would be simple but it wasn't it really
really wasn't it was quite different and
that's kind of what Illustrated to us
that like collider bias is happening
here
I think that's super important certainly
super important for you know not just
epidemiological research but for all
sorts of things where you may have some
sort of you know there's either a
self-selection bias or some sort of
another you know effect that you know
people who are interested in whatever it
is you're interested in uh might also be
those who are the most likely to
volunteer to be a subject somehow so it
affects your you think you're sampling
the population but really you're
sampling the collider whatever that
happens to be
um so I think it's it's a really
important thing that we again I wasn't
really familiar with and I imagine a lot
of data scientists who don't really pay
much attention to and possibly should
um you also talked about
um kind of the um unhealthy versus
healthy um and you had a nice little
graphic that showed how the unhealthy
kind of drives the the ve in One
Direction and The Healthy drives it in
the other direction do those cancel each
other out on the whole or is one more
powerful than another leaves a lingering
residue of bias if you know what I mean
yeah well that that's a very good
question I think it really depends on
your population
so if you were to try to assess ve in a
healthcare worker population you might
have healthy vaccine bias but if you're
trying to assess ve and like care home
like long-term care facility population
you might have bias towards them all
um so you know kind of a population wide
level thing like how we did in Ontario
it's possible that they cancel each
other out but it's hard to know exactly
what the magnitude of either one is in
either direction unless you kind of
really have a clear understanding of
like what are the underlying structures
and how is the vaccine being prioritized
to this population or that one over time
what now people have obviously your
focus is on
covid-19
vaccines and their effectiveness
these sorts of things that you've
discussed what if we replaced
covid-19 vaccine with
hydrochloroquine for example and yolk
would you you would see some of these
same effects you know the biases would
creep in the various uh glider biases
for
whatever reason they're called they're
in
are these effects are going to be
present there too am I correct yeah
absolutely and for for like Therapeutics
and things like hydroxychloroquine and
you know we have like special questions
that we specifically ask about vaccines
like waning immunity or viral
interference
um for Therapeutics there may be other
questions like were you taking another
drug at the same time
um are are you like did you take a drug
five years ago that might affect their
pharmacology of the drug that you're
taking currently
um and so there is like a little bit of
a difference in terms of like the actual
um some of the actual bias questions
because of the biological mechanisms of
the of the drug but you're absolutely
right that like General collider bias
can be found anywhere uh and especially
in places where we don't have complete
or proper case ascertainment covid-19 is
a great example of that
um or where we don't
um equitably assign people to receive uh
the thing that we think prevents the
outcome so vaccines or drugs
as your child is actually a pretty good
example of that where you know we feel
like it works but maybe it doesn't work
as well against emicron and so
um we were continuing to provide it in
certain scenarios but there's
differences in providing practices and
then it's changing over time too with
the emergence of Omicron variants and so
that also like kind of adds I guess like
a layer of complexity that not
necessarily is not necessarily like at
the top of our minds or to dining a
study to to assess these things
can you comment on any other things that
people who are data scientists or who
are attempting to say take data from a
national repository or some large you
know place where they could get access
to this what are some modeling
techniques some additional things that
people need to be aware of who are data
scientists who are usually just you know
we're going to apply machine learning
and it's going to machines are going to
sort it all out what are some of the
again there be dragons provisions and
provisos they need to be aware of yeah
well
that's a very good question
um
I have a couple of thoughts like things
that I would prefer to do but I'm
curious if anyone else has in the chat
or online or whatever has like thoughts
of you know stuff that would be best
practices
so um one of the first things that I
usually do is to do things a couple of
different ways and see if I get the same
answer and if I don't get the same
answer I think I start to think well
okay maybe there's something weird
happening here and that's what happened
in the Ontario data and that's kind of
how we were like oh actually there's
there's maybe some collider bias
happening
um one of the ways that you could try to
find out whether the assumptions of the
test native design are held for example
if you wanted to use that design study
design
is that you could
analyze the data a different way you
could use like a Cox proportional
hazards model or you could use something
that's not a gln and see if you get a
relatively similar ve estimate and if
you don't then that's a sign that some
of the assumptions that at least one of
your models has been violated right
because
in theory there's only one underlying
truth and in theory you've built your
model to estimate that underlying truth
so if it's different than the truth if
they're different from each other then
one of them is different than the trees
maybe both of them are and then you have
to figure out like difference between
truth either because if not specify my
model correctly or because one of the
assumptions is broken
um so so that's kind of like why I
generally tend to do that but I think
like even more than that for me
um and this is partly because I'm an
academic who's like a big procrastinator
and also a curious person
I like I really like to delve into like
actually what does this data mean
if we have like a covid-19 positive in
the data set does that mean that they
were tested at a community health clinic
does that mean that they reported on the
phone that they had a positive test does
that mean that they had sudden loss of
taste and smell and someone in their
house had covid but they didn't actually
ever get tested does it mean that
they're a healthcare provider who had no
symptoms and they kept getting tested
every single day because that was their
workplace safety requirements and then
one day it turned positive even now they
they never noticed any kind of symptoms
and like all those to me are really
different and they kind of carry with
them different kind of scenarios in the
subject
um so I think like it's it can be really
challenging to do this because when
you're working with something like big
data it kind of comes to you all
packaged really nicely at least in a lot
of scenarios maybe not every scenario
but in in the case of the Ontario data
it's like it's a nice Cut data set
we have a data dictionary we have like a
we we feel like we have like a complete
understanding of what's going on here
and it's not until like our assumptions
are challenged by the data itself that
we start saying oh actually like does
this really mean my thought it meant and
I think that's where it gets into the
importance of like you you really
actually it is worthwhile to find out
what that variable really means like
deep deep down
um I don't know that's a little bit of a
soapbox I think from an epidemiologist
but if you don't want to do that or you
can't do it maybe you can't do it do it
a lot of different ways and see if it's
different and if it's not different then
maybe maybe you really do have the right
model and that would be amazing great
one final question for you what to your
mind is one of the best data resources
out there for covid-19
data variables incidence rates you know
that that would be suitable for
large-scale Mining and Analysis
a couple of different really good
databases on their website and I would
actually recommend checking them out but
depending on where you live you may also
have like really good local data that
has been provided some local and like
State uh City Health departments provide
that data in Excel spreadsheets which is
amazing
um otherwise I know that you can if
you're like really into it and you
really want to get this data out of
their website you can do like a web
scraping they're they're cool with that
some um some states do Wastewater
surveillance and they have the
Wastewater surveillance results also
posted on their website in a really nice
Lake and that's that is really big data
because that's like
um they they sample wastewater treatment
facilities like with some kind of
frequency every week uh and depending on
like the size of the testing program it
might be like every Wastewater Treatment
Facility in the state over time so
that's that's something that is like
very interesting I think to dig into
um and you might find something really
cool or like very odd there which I
think maybe those are synonymous
um
but yeah that's that's what I would do I
mean the other if you have a connection
with like
um the the hospital
um or the like University Health System
um they will also have a lot of data and
it's possible that they have so much
data that they need to analyze it uh and
maybe you could maybe you could play
that role so yeah I would actually
um I would take a quick look first on
the CDC website they've got a couple of
really cool data sets
um for for the circulating variants and
for uh just a number of cases per day
per per um public health unit that's
fantastic well Maria thank you so much
that was a very fascinating and engaging
talk I really enjoyed that I hope that
uh our kind of listeners did as well
um I want to thank you again and I want
to thank everybody who uh joined us both
here in Zoom as well as out on YouTube
um do I do encourage you to apply for
our biomedical data science Innovation
lab uh event coming up and uh with a
deadline for applications is January 8th
so please consider doing that if you're
a junior faculty interested in
um covid-19 the second very health
effects and the role that data science
can play we'd love to entertain your
materials in the meantime everyone have
a wonderful weekend and we'll see you
next week thank